nein mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren herzlich willkommen heute zu so
einem spiel das bin ich in einem topf
ich steuere diese person in dem ich
einfach meine maus so bewege und das aha
so ich kann ja auch den stein bisschen
kratzen so bewege ich mich auf jeden
fall vorwärts emig muss dann hier
irgendwie rum klettern und kann dann
hier hoch die mich hier festhalten hier
rückbau mein gott den stunt gerade
gesehen und dann kann ich mich halt
irgendwie überbrücken hier rüber
springen und kommt und hier über jäger
das
das war ziemlich beschissen allerdings
ist das ganze nicht weiter schlimm denn
wir sind ja gewillt zu lernen
ich hatte mich davon da oben runter du
sollst auf den scheiß bauen ist es
überhaupt die richtige richtung in die
ich hier gerade laufe weil hier baden
gehen kann ich also nicht ich habe mich
ja von den berg herunter gestoßen über
die achse das heißt theoretisch wenn ich
ja so machen würde aber ich kann nicht
mehr ich kann nicht komplett
hochspringen das heißt wir gehen die
wieder gleichermaßen hoch irgendwie so
war das ja hier kommen konnte gab dann
ernst irgendwie ja ok das sieht war ganz
komisch aus jetzt nehmen wir die axt und
gehen hier rum und ziehen uns hier hoch
okay ich bin wieder an den baum jetzt
müssen wir uns mal ganz doll überlegen
wie wir das machen und zwar gehe ich
hier hoch o&o mein gott oh ja es
geschafft das war allerdings erst die
erste hürde denn wir müssen hier
natürlich noch ja einfach mal mit einem
stock rumknutschen ich probiere das
ganze jetzt mal ein bisschen weiter hier
vorne anzufassen das heißt jetzt schnell
oben dreht kommt nur geschafft hast hier
die axt hin und jetzt in diese richtung
rhein
da liegt doch einfach sollen gekenterte
schiff ich hab das spiel bei casey
gesehen in dem video und ich fand so
krasse lustig dass ich mir gedacht ich
muss das spiel auch spiel normal also
bei kaiser das wirklich sehr sehr
bescheuerte aus
du fährst jetzt nicht noch mal runter
das kann doch nicht so schwer sein über
diesen kalkberg die rüberzukommen kummer
wie schnell ich hier auch allein
mittlerweile schon durch komme ich mag
einfach die axt hier rum und sagt bin
ich wieder unten kompakt die axt hier an
haut dich darum und jetzt müssen wir so
sehr gut jetzt hier acht kacke
die solchen solchen da hochkommen ich
kann sogar so auf der axt balancieren
alter ich mache jetzt mal ganz
vorsichtig ich drück mich hier so ein
bisschen weg genau hier noch so ein
bisschen weg gehen und jetzt kann ich
mich hier mit der axt ich werde eine
helikopter hier hochziehen und noch mal
hoch und ich kann mich hoch stoßen
vielleicht hält so hier
dann okay okay okay ich hätte mein gott
du denkst ich dachte wirklich schon
diese fortnight job hat mich an meine
nerven grenzen gebracht aber dieses
spiel egal wo stoße ich da hoch also
hier ganz vorsichtig die axt nehmen und
hochdrücken werden ok sind da oben jetzt
ja an der seite hoch und ich ja das
sieht gemütlich aus es kann doch nicht
so schwer sein ich glaube diesen satz
ist kann nicht so schwer sind habe ich
schon so oft in welchen videos gesagt wo
es tatsächlich doch dann recht schwer
war immer also die axt nach unten und
dann hochdrücken dann kann ich mich hier
hochziehen okay das ist schon mal sehr
gut aus einem jetzt die achsen langsam
hier zur seite dass ich hier stehen kann
genauso gut jetzt muss ich ein bisschen
ja nicht viel drin ganz klein bisschen
genauer muss ich noch hier sehr gut und
jetzt die axt hier rum und macht spaß
ist also das hier ist wirklich gerade
sondern bereich da kann man wirklich nur
sagen menschenrechte sind sämtlich
abstoßen wir gehen diesmal ganz bedacht
vor schubste mich hier ganz leicht nach
vorne genau hier die dings ich drücke
mich hoch und klemme unterm stein so
hänge ich in der luft gehe so hinz
abstoß mich hoch und binnen wieder weg
drücke mich hoch und das war sehr schön
das war sehr schön das war sehr schon
jetzt ganz langsam hierhin axt nicht
loslassen ganz langsam herum sehr gut
nun nehmen wir wieder ganz langsam die
axt drücken uns hier wieder nur ganz
bisschen weg genau so dass wir nicht
runterfallen wohl
das hier
ist das spiel ich fresse steht das schon
seit vorgestern er ist tut mir leid dass
ich diesen satz so oft sagen aber das
kann doch nicht so schwer sein ich mein
ich drück mich einfach hier hoch das ist
man braucht zum spielen uhr die
mausbewegung eine tastenkombination man
muss jetzt nicht treppen bauen wie in
fortnight lege ich muss mich nur mit
meiner maus herumdrücken und irgendwie
dann auf diesen felsvorsprung schaffen
und wenn ich das mache dann hat es
gerade geklappt geklappt es war sehr gut
ganz langsam und vorsichtig ihr
wegdrücken ganz langsam lokal ganz ganz
ganz ganz langsam ich glaube ich muss
mich allerdings noch ein wenig weiter
weg drücken hier auf die kante denn nur
dann wenn ich jetzt genau hier stehe nur
dann kommt meine axt hier rum und jetzt
freunde
es schaut zu ich bin hier
da haben wir erst mal die axt
hochschrecken also ich befinde mich
jetzt hier auf diesem komischen
rudergerät ich glaube jetzt muss ich
nehme ich hier mich ganz ganz ganz ganz
langsam und warte moment nein du bleibst
du sax weg und jetzt hier auf den baum
um mein gott das ding ist nur dass ich
jetzt hier nicht weiß wie ich da oben
dran kommen soll
ich glaube eine möglichkeit wäre es dass
ich mich hier wegdrücken kann ich noch
einsteigen in den applaus
nein nein nein
[Musik]
heute kann ich das doch mal bitte in der
slow bausch sei der traurigste moment
glaube ich den es je bei diesem spiel
gar falls ihr euch fragen wie diese
spiele überhaupt heißt das heißt getting
aufwand weil man über das ding was da
steht halt darüber kommen muss und ich
jetzt mal wieder so vor wie vorhin also
ich gebe mich erst mal hierhin dann muss
ich mich jetzt ganz langsam wieder
wegdrücken
oh mein gott
okay ich bin wieder an der gleichen
stelle freunde ich weiß wirklich nicht
wie ich hier jetzt vorgehen muss ich
drücke mich erstmal hier ein wenig weg
sodass sich auf den stamm hier ein
bisschen drauf komme und stehe nun so
ich glaube ich muss mich wirklich hier
jetzt hochdrücken sack und bin nun hier
oben auf dem stein die sache ist nur oh
mein gott oh mein gott oh mein gott
okay okay ich bin krass gut nein man
muss sich in solchen videos einfach
zwischendurch so ein bisschen selbst
motivieren
ich glaube ich muss mich hier wieder
hochdrücken nein
ok wieder zurück jetzt muss ich ganz
vorsichtig vorgehen ich drücke mich noch
ein wenig weiter denn das hier ist ja
extra so ein bisschen schräg das heißt
ich drücke mich nun hier weg nein
ok versuch nummer zwei duca versuch
nummer zwei okay okay
luca kommen hier macht ihr nichts vor
das ist wirklich eine klasse leistung
die ich hier bisher gerade erbracht habe
mich glaube ich muss mich allerdings
ließ man ein wenig weiter hierhin bewege
ich drücke mich hier hoch und ganz
schnell und wieder hoch und hoch hierhin
und dahin kommt luca hkj ich habe es
geschafft ein paar sekunden später okay
wenn man runterfällt darf man nicht die
nerven verlieren
man muss sich da wieder ganz
normal und gut hocharbeiten ist nicht
wahr ist nicht war das jetzt mein
letzter schritt nach oben freunde ich
gehe hier hin genau muss mich hier
hinstellen und nun hier über die axt an
dem stock eine schnelle umdrehung jetzt
das ganze ist natürlich wieder so ein
bisschen schwieriger ich muss mich hier
okay bleib ruhig
hierhin schild hoch und zack da sind wir
auf dem stein der haupt tipp den man
jemanden in diesem spiel wirklich geben
kann ist geduld man muss wirklich ganz
ganz vorsichtig vorgehen das bringt
nichts über hastige bewegungen bringen
gar nichts das heißt ich muss mich jetzt
aber leute das sind kurze herzinfarkte
immer hier hochdrücken und hier
festhalten sehr gut luca nun muss ich
mich wieder hier auf den stein nein oh
mein gott
[Musik]
als ich mein kopf ok ok top-leute was
war das bitte gerade was was war das
gerade für ein kranker randen leute ich
bin aber ganz ehrlich diese position
hier die behalten wir jetzt ich speicher
das ab und bei 50.000 lights kommt
nächste woche ein neuer part von diesem
spiel also wenn euch das video hier
gefallen hat das gerne einen daumen hoch
bei diesem video hier daher schreibt mir
gern und in die kommentare irgendwelche
tipps für dieses spiel und abonniert
main kanal weißt du noch keinen teil
meiner community sein
[Musik]